before we get to today's video we have a
quick announcement we're testing out a
new show called
origins of food if you want to learn
more about why wagyu beef is so
expensive or
why everyone is eating crickets then
this show is for you
and the more you watch the more videos
we might be able to make
caviar whether you're a foodie or not
chances are you
have some opinions on this food for some
people
the thought of eating fish eggs even
once
is gross enough to turn them into vegans
but what if you only ate caviar
for a month how much money would you
spend
could caviar improve your love life
or would it break your heart
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you ate nothing but caviar for a
month
once only royalty could eat caviar but
in the 19th century this salty snack
became a bar food in the united states
this seafood treat took the world by
storm and
nearly wiped out the sturgeon fish the
high demand for a nearly extinct fish's
eggs
raised caviar prices once again
only the rich could afford to enjoy
these precious
bite-sized morsels today airlines
purchase 50 percent of the world's
supply of caviar
to feed their first class passengers
but if this was all you ate would you
get the nutrition you need to survive
the rules are simple no vitamin
supplements
or spreading caviar on toast you'll only
be consuming caviar
and water and ditch the fancy silverware
metals taint the taste of the fish eggs
so
use your favorite plastic spork instead
in polite society you might take two
spoonfuls of caviar
at the most what are you doing but since
this is your
only source of nutrition that's not
going to be enough
and don't expect this stuff to be cheap
we'll get into that in a minute while it
takes some adjusting to get used to this
food
you might feel some positive effects
during the first part of this diet
for example caviar has a high level
of acetylcholine which is a
neurotransmitter
involved in retaining memories your mom
always told you that
fish was brain food acetylcholine
also lines the stomach and increases
your body's tolerance to alcohol
and 16 grams of caviar contains
just over a thousand milligrams of
omega-3 fatty acids
which can prevent blood clots and lower
your cholesterol
okay so for the first few weeks your
skin might improve and
your joints could even feel better and
your dating life
may improve too after all caviar
contains arginine which increases blood
flow so
this slimy treat might be a powerful
aphrodisiac
but you may not want to get your heart
pumping
too fast as you get further into this
month
you could start to feel the effects of
all the sodium
racing through your system the food and
drug administration recommends
only consuming milligrams of sodium per
day
so if you're eating caviar for every
meal
you might consume up to eleven thousand
two hundred and eighty milligrams of
sodium
more than five times the daily
recommendation
your blood pressure might go through the
roof
increasing your risk of having a stroke
or developing heart disease
remember caviar was introduced as a bar
food to get patrons craving more beer
consuming only this salty seafood would
make you very thirsty and your
kidneys can only take so much sodium
before they start to retain water you
could start to feel bloated and
your hands and feet would swell you
might
suffer from hypernatremia if the amount
of sodium in your body is too high
you could also have problems sleeping
breathing
urinating have seizures go into a coma
or even die and since you're not eating
anything that provides vitamin c
you're at risk of getting scurvy early
symptoms
include nausea or diarrhea but later on
you might have bruised scaly skin or
bleeding gums
so how could you keep eating the caviar
fine dining experts agree that the best
way is to
feel the eggs with your tongue instead
of chewing them
since your teeth might be falling out
that would be easy for you
and all that animal magnetism you had
earlier
would definitely be gone now
if you think your medical bills might be
high check out the price of the caviar
sturgeon row can cost anywhere from 65
to 85 dollars for 30 grams
your body needs at least 2 000 calories
a day to survive
so to get that amount you would have to
eat
almost one kilogram daily
this month's supply of caviar could cost
you over
60 thousand dollars and
that's eating the cheap stuff
going into debt and dying slowly from
sodium poisoning
probably isn't the way you want to spend
any month
maybe you'd better stick to the two
spoonfuls rule
and leave the rest of the caviar for
other people
but hey you made it through a month of
eating
one of the saltiest snacks on earth
so now let's go for something sweet
what if you only ate sugar for a month
well that's a story for another
what if